m
[Musique]
[Rires]
des personnes 93 ans récupère au beau
milieu de l'aréna jacques-lemaire la
patinoire a été transformée il ya quatre
semaines en hôpital de campagne pour
accueillir des patients infectés par le
corona virus une première au québec
donc on s'apprête à rentrer dans la zone
chaude on a exactement le même matériel
que tout le personnel soignant ici ça
fait le terme à cinq minutes que j'ai ce
au visage je peux comprendre qu'avec à
travailler avec cet équipement là ça
peut être confortable éventuels on vous
suit connu une dizaine des pentes comme
celle là chacune des tentes peut
accueillir jusqu'à quatre patients on a
vraiment tout l'équipement qu'une unité
de médecine chirurgie générale dans un
centre hospitalier où pourrait avoir
toutes les tentes qu'on voit ici sont
normalement utilisée par la croix rouge
dans le cadre de crise humanitaire ou de
catastrophes naturelles et elles ont
aussi été utilisés pour combattre ebola
donc au delà des tentes
on n'a pas l'impression d'être dans un
hôpital de brousse ou non nient tout de
même dans un aréna c'est assez
particulier comme environnement au début
de la pandémie le sus de l'ouest de
l'île de montréal espérer ne pas avoir à
utiliser cet hôpital mobile pour
accueillir des patients passés pour cela
on le monte est toujours dans les eaux
cause où il ya déjà d'autres sites non
traditionnels qui sont en train de se
construire présentement
aujourd'hui le personnel soignant
travail s'il fait façon volontaire et
jusqu'à maintenant tous les besoins sont
comblés sur le territoire du sud de
l'ouest de l'île de montréal
on dénombre une vingtaine de foyers
d'éclosion dans des ch et celle des
aidants des centres hospitaliers la
clientèle initial était vraiment la
clientèle du csld de la région delà de
la salle pourrait délaisser jeu celle
des on n'avait pas la capacité dans les
hôpitaux donc fallait qu'on dit qu'on
augmente notre capacité
d'hospitalisation et c'est comme ça
qu'on est arrivé à ce concepteur
[Musique]
si le virus a épargné dit wilson
certains de ses voisins n'ont pas eu la
même chance madame est désormais à
symptomatique
elle attend maintenant d'être testés à
nouveau pour avoir son congé
[Musique]
il